Child of the elder blood starry-eyed
daughter of chaos join our hunt
i'm the one who ordered the
death of that elven baby
it was the best path to
helping me find my daughter
Welcome back everyone toss a coin to your
witcher this is going to be my full witcher
season 2 netflix video there are so many big
reveals things that happen so we'll break it
all down lots of easter eggs from the books they
jumped around in the timeline quite a bit too
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos they've already
confirmed season 3 like they do have a plan to
make it through all of the book stories so if
you're worried about that do not worry they even
have a spin-off prequel series called witcher
blood origin about the very first witchers there
were a lot of scenes and easter eggs that they
included in the last couple of episodes of season
2 that helped set that up so i'll explain what
those things were during the video but careful for
spoilers for everything that happened if you have
not seen season 2 yet but season 2 mostly adapted
the book story from blood of elves because that's
the next book after the story they did for season
one mostly now they changed some things they
jumped around the timeline a little bit like they
had some big reveals with ciri's father emperor
emhyr of nilfgaard and the wild hunt which don't
really happen until the very end of the books
they included some video game easter eggs in
season two and the video game plot doesn't pick
up till after the books end and they circled back
around doing some big story that they skipped over
during season one from the early short stories
which takes place earlier in the timeline so
we'll start with the biggest wtf moments in
easter eggs like the wild hunt series father
emhyr the white frost ithlinne's prophecy as well
as the multiverse reveal and then i'll cover the
other stuff like all the easter eggs that help
set up the witcher prequel series blood origin
so first things first they end the season on
the reveal of the wild hunt itself and this
isn't meant to be a vision that ciri geralt and
yennefer are having they are not hallucinating
this they are legit physically on a different
planet when this is happening so when you see
the wild tunt riding towards them on the beach
that's really happening if ciri hadn't used her
power to portal them back to the main planet of
the witcher series where they came from the wild
tunt would have taken her they want ciri just like
every other main faction on the show wants her but
for slightly different reasons everyone has a
slightly different reason for wanting her power
some want her for political reasons some want
her for magical reasons they did a little bit
of her jedi witcher training during season 2 like
they kind of trained her in the witcher arts but
she's still very very young at this point so the
origin of ciri's elder blood which is a big plot
point during this season that's what the title
blood evolves as a reference to the blood that
flows in her veins the elder blood but multiverse
travel between worlds if you did not realize the
witcher series is actually a science fiction story
in disguise it's not just magic swords and dragons
that feels weird but i'll allow it we just
started talking about the multiverse in the
marvel universe like spiderman no way home is a
multiverse movie but the origin of series elder
blood multiverse travel and the origin of the wild
hunt are all connected so thousands of years ago
the elders that they speak of during season two
like the elder blood in her veins vesmer thinks
he needs ciri's elder blood to create new witcher
mutagen so that he can create more witchers elders
are the original race of elves that lived on this
main planet thousands of years ago as vesimir says
all the humans think that they died out a long
time ago and the elves that you do see running
around with francesca during the show like you see
them up at nilfgaard during the later part of the
season those are a different group of elves that
weren't part of the elders like they're like a
completely separate bloodline but what happened is
that during the first conjunction of the spheres
conjunctions happen every couple thousand
years the barriers between universes weaken
and it's much easier to travel between universes
so if you saw the trailer for the witcher blood
origin for that prequel series they're doing the
first conjunction of the spheres during that you
see like this green lightning in the sky that's
the conjunction of the spheres beginning to happen
during this first conjunction of the spheres a
group of these elder elves used the conjunction
to travel to another world in the multiverse and
claim it as their own like a new realm to conquer
they conquered this new world by killing all the
humans that were there but they found that they
actually needed a lot of slave labor so they found
another gateway that would allow them to travel
between universes and created a group that would
go around to different worlds and steal humans
for more slave labor that group was called the red
riders but then was later renamed to the wild hunt
led by eredin who you see riding down the beach at
ciri geralt and yennefer at the end of the series
so way back when this first conjunction of the
spheres is happening another member of their race
these elders ethelene who was a prophet created
her prophecy about the white frost to make a game
of thrones reference is a very winter is coming
kind of prophecy the white frost in the world of
the witcher is like a planet killing climate
change force of nature like an ice age that
will basically kill all life on any planet that it
comes to an extinction level event so the separate
group of elves that went to this different planet
where the wild hunt comes from they were worried
about the white frost killing their planet they
used a selective breeding program within their
race to create a being imbued with enough magical
power to stop the white frost ciri is just the
current person in present day to inherit the
power through the specific bloodline now she's
just the latest in a long bloodline so there are
other bastards who rose up along the area so there
are other people who might have potential for the
elder blood ciri's not the only person but she's
just the person who has the purest form of the
elder blood within her what happened when they
started the elder blood program though is that
the king of this race of elves had a daughter who
was supposed to marry another elf of their race
and pass the bloodline along to their child her
name was lara dorren which might sound familiar we
actually saw her at the end of the witcher season
too like ciri has a vision of her with her baby
that's basically like syria's great great great
great great great great grandmother she kind of
foobared the whole elder blood program by falling
in love with a human mage and passed her elder
blood to their daughter that you see here her name
was rihanna so she was half elf and that's where
ciri's elven blood her elder blood comes from like
ciri herself is part elf yennefer is also part
elf so that little girl rhiannon married another
human on the main world of the witcher and so on
and so forth till the elder blood was eventually
passed down to ciri from her mother pavetta and
obviously she was married to a father emhyr the
rightful king of nilfgaard but the blood came
through her mother pavetta not through emhyr
ciri's full name cirilla fiona ellen riannon is a
combination of all the names of her ancestors like
this is what her family tree looks like where the
wild hunt gets involved in all this is like i said
the original elven king from this other planet
that the elders went to had all the humans from
their new world eradicated so they needed more
slave labor he decreed the special cavalry unit be
created with the mission of invading other worlds
in the multiverse to get more slaves and resources
he called them the red riders then they were later
renamed to the wild hunt but he named aerodyn the
leader of the wild hunt here as their captain
they used a special gateway between worlds they
discovered and on the show those special obelisks
that ciri manipulates to open gateways that's the
show's version of that she opens a couple gateways
to another world one to bring basilisks to their
world when she's being controlled by their version
of baba yaga the witch that possesses her then she
opens another gateway taking them to the planet
that the wild hunt comes from this other group
of elder elves so when the red riders started
invading other planets they wore special skeletal
armor they used their magic to make themselves
seem more intimidating just to inspire fear in the
people that they were raiding so underneath that
armor they look just like the other elves that you
see on the show but their race lives for a long
time so aerodyn has been doing this since the
very first conjunction of the spheres thousands of
years ago so when the red riders start doing this
eventually they discover the original planet that
their race came from the main world of the witcher
where ciri where geralt come from and the funny
kind of ironic thing is that the group of elves
that the wild hunt comes from hates the other
faction of their race the other elders that stayed
behind on the original planet of the witcher so
once they find the original plant they came from
they start enslaving the other members of their
race that stayed behind and because there are
so many humans proliferating on that main world
of the witcher they also begin to take them back
to their other planet as slaves the other funny
thing is that the magic that they use to power
the gateways between worlds is actually driven
by these special multiverse unicorns who have the
natural ability to travel between worlds they're
like these extra dimensional beings that look kind
of like unicorns eventually the wild hunt can't
find any more unicorns so they begin to lose the
ability to access the gateway between worlds and
they still want to go around conquering other
worlds so once they learn of serious existence
like oh this is a person who has the elder blood
they learn that she has enough power to access the
gateway between worlds like ciri portals geralt
and yennefer to this other planet with their own
power once the wild hunt learns about that they
want ciri so that they can access the gateway and
conquer more worlds but you also have to remember
that the wild tunt comes from the group of elves
that started the elder blood program to stop the
white frost so they're members of their race that
are still afraid of the white frost and they want
ceres power to stop that but eredin and the wild
hunt mostly just want her so that they can conquer
more worlds of the multiverse but ciri doesn't
actually fight the wild hunt themselves physically
until the events of the video games which take
place much later in the timeline after the events
of the books have ended so they might accelerate
that on the tv show quite a bit moving on to the
next big reveal her father is emperor emhyr
that's a completely separate thing like all
the stuff with the wild hunt is totally different
from what's happening with emhyr in the books you
don't really learn about the connection to emhyr
to the very last book but the reason he wants ciri
is more about stopping the white frost and using
her power to conquer the planet during season 1
and season 2 they call him the white flame and
he's in the middle of this campaign to conquer
the entire continent like they start with cintra
eventually another secret villain on the show
vilgefortz starts working with emhyr telling him
all about ethelene's prophecy of the white frost
and that's how he learns of ciri's true value
like oh not only is she really powerful and
she can defeat armies we also have this giant ice
age that could kill the entire planet so we might
need her for that as well but emhyr doesn't really
learn about the white frost till later he mostly
wants ciri to conquer the planet for political
reasons and even though they tease him doing a
couple really terrible things during season two
like killing francesca's child like oh that was
me that did that there are things that he did that
were way worse involving ciri's mother that i'll
talk about later once they reveal that on the show
i don't want to get too much into that because
there's more backstory for his character like they
only tease what he was doing between the events of
season one and season two because remember we only
see him in the flashbacks of season one we don't
see him in the present day of season one like all
this stuff with the curse coming off of him that's
happening before ciri is born they'll probably
tease more of his backstory and all the other
terrible stuff that he did after this in season 3.
but overall his story during season 3 will be like
an accelerated version of what you've seen between
the books and the games eventually ciri will
probably come face to face with him maybe about
like season four or season five and she'll have
to reject him because by that point geralt will be
the person that she truly thinks of as her father
she kind of already does that during season two
papa bless all the stuff with riots during season
two is right out of the books blood of elves
he's kind of like the main villain of this
book that they did for the story but in the books
he's secretly working for vilga forts and on the
show they've only really hinted at vulgar forts
having some ulterior motives or some other plan
he's not a really huge character during season
two and during the season two episodes they never
fully reveal who ryan's is working for but it's
supposed to be vilgefortz and vilga fort's like
take it one step back is supposed to be working
for emperor emhyr although separately vilgefortz
has his own reasons for wanting series power but
he doesn't really become a main villain character
till much later in the books because they're
speeding so many other big plot twists up they
might also speed that reveal up too right now the
show wants you to think that the main villain is
emperor emhyr ciri's father like full-on darth
vader reveal but the thing is in the series there
isn't really any one main villain everyone is
kind of different levels of terrible but next big
thing all the stuff with vesemir creating that new
witcher mutagens with ciri's blood the scenes with
lara dorren and her daughter ciri's great great
great great great grandmother many times removed
it all the talk about the conjunction of the
spheres was meant to set up the witcher prequel
series blood origin the title is a reference
to the origin of the witcher mutagen that human
and elven sorcerers use to create the first
witchers like i said the green lightning that
you see in the trailer here is during the first
conjunction of the spheres while it's taking place
they haven't revealed all the characters on the
show but you will definitely recognize michelle
yeoh playing this elven sorceress the books in the
games haven't really covered a ton about the very
first witchers they've only hinted at that story
so the show will take that and kind of extrapolate
based on sapkowski's notes they haven't said
exactly when they plan on releasing season three
hopefully at the end of next year but that will
cover most of the events of the next book forward
in the timeline time of contempt but just like
season two they will add extra stuff from later
in the timeline like that will continue during
season three they just introduced dijkstra's
character the head of redanian intelligence played
by graham mctavish who you'll recognize from a
bunch of other shows and movies he becomes a much
bigger antagonist for a geralt ciri and yennefer
during season 3 in redania has this big plan to
try and conquer the continent they teased during
season two that will become a bigger thing in
season three as will the story of the elves led
by francesca they fight for nilfgaard but they
don't wear their colors because of that secret
plan orchestrated by emhyr making them think that
redania was responsible for killing their child
so the war between different realms on the
continent will heat up in future seasons very game
of thronesy like war of the five kings flashbacks
but if there any other big questions that you have
from season two that i didn't answer in this
video or other easter eggs that you spotted
that i didn't talk about just write them below in
the comments big reminder i'll be doing episode
videos for the star wars book of boba fett my full
episode one video will post next wednesday in a
couple of days when they release that it's kind
of like the mandalorian season 2.5 with a bunch
of mandalorian characters crossing over like
mando grogu maybe boca tan maybe some others
while you wait for that click here to learn about
the spider-man no way home alternate ending in
all the deleted scenes and click here for my full
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your witcher!